[Music]
Disney loves to leave its mark on every
single movie that comes its way so
knowing this it's not surprising that
the Nutcracker in the four realms is
riddled with Disney connections watch
until the end to find out why critics
are saying that this film is a spitting
image of Alice in Wonderland's first
time at the things don't forget to hit
that subscribe button and give this
video a big thumbs up now let's bring
the nutcrackers Disney connections to
light my favorite part of this evening I
present to you your gifts The Chronicles
of Narnia one look at The Nutcracker in
the four rooms is all you need to
connect it to the Lion the Witch in the
Wardrobe both stories take off in a
similar fashion placing its protagonist
in the winter season with heavy hearts
whereas Lucy Edmund Susan and Peter are
sent to their professor's house to
escape the war Clara and her family
attempt to remember their late mother
during the Christmas season both stories
are a play on a child's imagination
which subjects us to vivid imagery and
silly moments much like The Chronicles
of Narnia Clara is given the task of
saving a foreign land that she stumbled
into I hope you'll be the one to finish
it it's time to save the kingdom which
proves to be a lot more challenging than
she's led to believe
despite their similar plots these two
movies managed to create very different
tones and this is due to how unique
their animation styles are on top of
that these Disney flicks are 100 percent
age-appropriate making it easy for
parents to bring their kids to the movie
theaters the Nutcracker in the four
realms is an emotional movie with many
core morals and values to offer the U
and much like The Chronicles of Narnia
it teaches us that were never too young
to make a difference Beauty and the
Beast you might have noticed that every
good Disney movie begins with a
significant loss this is a theme we've
seen over and over again well it looks
like the Nutcracker and the four realms
is no exception because well it begins
with the loss of Claire's wonderful
mother
was a clever Cinderella name did you
notice that the musical had a lot in
common with 1991 the Beauty and the
Beast because we sure did while there
are some apparent differences between
the two productions here's our point
first off Belle and Clara are a lot
alike they're independent intelligent
and selfless so much so that they'd risk
a life of imprisonment to save the
people they love secondly they're both
tasked with rescuing a dying world and
while their journeys might be different
their fate is the same without those
love the Beast and his lively palace
would be lost and forgotten and without
Clara's key the four realms would cease
to exist but perhaps the most
significant similarity of all is how
Belle and Clara were forced to see
something beautiful in the eyes of a
beast
on another note both of these characters
are said to be different than the other
girls
due to their indifference over trivial
matters like getting married or being
wanted and admired by others
although these brunettes might have
different missions they follow the same
heartfelt paths can you see the
similarities Moana it's only normal for
Disney movies to recycle old plots which
is why some critics felt as though they
were watching the same film with
different actors regardless of this the
Nutcracker in the four realms is a
wonder to watch and a spectacle to
behold and although it might follow a
familiar succession it is filled with
unique concepts that are glued together
with the help of talented CGI artists
well the Disney movie Moana might not
come to mind up first
we can't help but tie these two films
together and here's why Moana was given
the TPT's heart when she was just a
child and elected by the ocean to return
it to its rightful owner
without this heart Mona's world would
surely die and everyone she loved would
follow suit in The Nutcracker
Clara is given a key to the four realms
of Christmas later on she stumbles upon
a magical world and finds out that she
must use her Christmas present to rescue
the four realms from their precarious
fate the four realms were created by
Clara's late mother who used to tell
tales of them to her children before
bedtime
now Claire is tasked with keeping her
mother's memory alive by saving the
fantastical realms
although Moana and Clara are extremely
different characters they both know what
it's like to risk everything deceived
the world they love Fantasia in 1940
Disney released the animated classic
that would forever go down in history
Fantasia is made up of eight
surrealistic pieces that are brought to
life with music dance and animation
amongst these eight pieces is the
Nutcracker Suite which was created by a
team of dedicated dancers designers and
animators although little known this
Disney film would never have seen the
light of day if it hadn't been for a
group of talented young women knowing
this the Nutcracker in the four realms
saw fit to include feminism into their
plot or should we say their playlists
although many people did not notice at
first the song playing over the
Nutcracker trailer is none other than no
Doubt's hit track just a girl
[Music]
little only don't let me out of yours
well it might be dramatically slowed
down to fit the tone this song was
chosen for a reason the track is about a
young woman who desperately wants to
break free of the mold so much like its
predecessor the Nutcracker was made to
embody the growth and empowerment of
women well Clara might feel as though
she's just a girl she's actually much
more than that when present in the
forums Clara is a princess who's tasked
with saving the world her late mother
created Alice in Wonderland knowing this
we aren't surprised that countless
directors took a page from Tim Burton's
book in 2010 the famous director was
tasked with bringing Alice in Wonderland
to life and he did an amazing job so
much so that nearly every Disney movie
that followed has been crowded with
heaps of CGI and while we're not
complaining we can't help but notice
that the Nutcracker in the four realms
is the spitting image of Alice in
Wonderland
for starters both stories tell the tale
of a young woman in a blue dress who's
coming of age not wanting to accept the
reality of their situation
these girls follow an unknown entity
through a rabbit hole while Alice falls
down a rabbit hole located at the base
of a big tree Clara walks through a
portal and emerges from a similar trunk
afterward both protagonists are informed
of their importance in saving the world
they've just entered and an evil queen
of some sorts wants them dead
antagonists mother ginger in the Queen
of Hearts both have red hair
wicked personalities and little minions
who do their bidding for them on top of
that both movies showcased sweet and
helpful characters like the Sugar Plum
Fairy and the white queen so knowing
what you know now can you see why
critics are saying that these movies are
won in the scene before you go let us
know what you thought about the
Nutcracker and the four realms in the
comment section below and that's a wrap
thanks for watching and see you next
time on the things
[Music]